hey what's up my name's samuel lee's
what i'm about to tell you
hopefully should blow your property
investment mind and for anybody that's
thinking
i know when samuel lee puts out these
prediction videos
does he really know what he's talking
about what's going to happen in the
future with property
let me just show you this okay this is
what nationwide bank said
they said i don't know if you can see
this darwin but they said in july
they published this july 2020 and they
said that the average house of a price
was two hundred and twenty thousand
pounds can you see that darwin
let me get a little bit closer look at
this july 2020
average price 220. can you see it yep
220 according to nationwide bank
220 july now
let's fast forward to the most recent
statement which was january
2021 the following year that's this year
average house price is now two two nine
seven
four eight last month this is the most
recent statement two two nine
seven four eight december was 2 30. can
you see that
now bear in mind that when they
published this in july time
everyone was saying that house prices
were about to crash
going down there was a lot of scare
mongering going on now i've done a whole
video of predictions
which i want you to check out i did a
whole video in june
but look what i said in july right
listen to this
okay july time house prices are around
about 220 000 pounds
my prediction is that by january next
year
they're gonna have gone up they're gonna
be around about 230 to 235 000 pounds
right now in the uk july time house
prices are around about 220
000 pounds my prediction is that by
january next year they're gonna have
gone up they're going to be around about
230 to 235 000 pounds on average per
house
like literally it's there
said right so and guess what when i said
that when i did that when i said that
everyone was on instagram even going i
don't think so
it's saying i don't know what i'm
talking about look just because i've got
a loud marmite personality and i use my
hands a lot
doesn't mean i don't know exactly what's
happening in the property market i did a
whole video check it out i'm going to
put it up i'm going to
i'm going to put it up as an end screen
in a second and i did the video in june
and i did a whole bunch of predictions
some of them were short-term some of
them were long-term
but nearly every single one of those
predictions right now
is happening is coming true and it's
about the property market and the
economy as a whole
so for all the people last year in 2020
that were like samuel doesn't know what
he's talking about
well let's just look back and look at
the straight facts
most people are really scared when they
do predictions they'll make a prediction
but they'll be really ambiguous and a
bit worried when i make a prediction
that prediction was literally
january 2021 i think house prices
are going to be about 230 000 pounds and
when i said it we weren't sure whether
the market was going to crash
it was gonna we no one had any idea
that's what i said
uh back back last year and now 2021
january
it's near enough exactly not only the
price that i said but the right time as
well
so there we have it i'm gonna put the
whole list up of predictions
uh so be careful you listen to there's a
lot of people making predictions and
talking a whole bunch of nonsense and
i'm gonna be calling some of these
people out as well soon because they
have
real strong agendas
i'm coming to get you
people have real strong agendas to get
more business when i'm making
predictions
i don't have adverts on this youtube
channel i'm just making a prediction
because i'm in the market and i'm
sharing
because most of the actual people that
are making money in property that are
doing hundreds of deals
they don't make prediction videos they
just quietly make money i don't quietly
make money i make money but i do it
openly
transparently and i share every step of
the way so that's that
check the full video out here i did this
in june last year coming up to a year
ago now
right and you can see it's all happening
everything i said it's all happening
and at the time when i said this
everyone was saying i was crazy if you
want to see more videos subscribe
smash the like button you can subscribe
right here i'll see you next time
thank you so much
you